*clapping* Please welcome to the stage Ashley.
*drum roll*
*clears throat*Guys, I'm dying.
Meow.
*trumpet*
What's up with this ice bucket challenge? The only ice wanna see poured over my head is the rapper. #arewethereyet
WHY?! #GameofThrones
@RyanSeacrest It's my birthdaaay!
Took me 45 minutes to get to work today on the 101. Thanks, Obama. #immigration
Hey everybody out there, got an improv show this weekend. #pleasecomeout #4drinkminimun #iwillbesadifyoudontcome
Please come.
Dolphins go into a murderous rage when they are sexually frustrated.
Check it out guys, I just met Michael Cera!
*from audience* That's not Michael Cera, dumbass! *laughing*
MAN: No, no, no, no, that's too good. Say that again. GIRL: Check it out guys, I just met Michael Cera. *laughing*
Oh, oh! I apologize, that was supposed to be a DM.
Follow me for a free iPad.
http://www.JCPenney.com/slippers
Your nipple hardens exactly 7 seconds after it is flicked.
Sunday funday! *clapping*
*clapping suddenly stops*
I don't even know who you are but I'm gonna make fun of you. *maniacal laugh*
Do hate when they're, um, serving you... dinner, and, uh... the waiter keeps calling you by... I'm sorry, uhh...